General Mark Milley completed a four-year term as chairman of the Joint Chiefs of Staff,
the nation's highest-ranking military officer on September 30th.
He told us he spent most of his time working to avoid a direct conflict with Russia and
China, while the country watched him have a very public falling out with former President
Trump, the man who picked him for the job.
More Milley's time serving President Joe Biden had its own challenges, including America's
calamitous withdrawal from Afghanistan, as well as providing Ukraine with billions of
dollars worth of American military equipment.
A few hours before we sat down with the general at the Pentagon, he had his final phone call
with the commander of Ukraine's armed forces.
The story will continue in a moment.
The counteroffensive that the Ukrainians are running is still ongoing.
The progress has many, many people have noted it is slow, but it is steady, and they are
making progress on a day-to-day basis.
But expelling 200,000 Russian soldiers, no easy tasks.
Very hard, very hard.
How long is this going to look like this, a year or five years?
Well, you can't put a time on it, but it will be a considerable length of time, and it's
going to be long and hard and very bloody.
Russia occupies 41,000 square miles of Ukraine.
The frontline extends about the distance from Atlanta to Washington, D.C.
In Congress this past week, Republicans ended Kevin McCarthy's speakership, and for now
more aid to Ukraine.
According to the White House of the $113 billion already committed, there is only enough left
to last a few more months.
With all of the issues facing Americans at home, why is this worth it?
If Ukraine loses and Putin wins, I think you would be certainly increasing if not doubling
your defense budget in the years ahead, and you will increase the probability of great
power war in the next 10 to 15 years.
I think it would be a very dangerous situation if Putin is allowed to win.
Ukraine, Russia obviously is what drives us meeting today.
The chairman of the Joint Chiefs is the commander-in-chiefs principal military advisor, but
commands no troops in battle.
I am obligated, regardless of consequences, to give my advice to the President, but no
President is obligated to follow that advice.
This past August, General Milley invited us aboard the USS Constitution in Boston Harbor,
not far from where he grew up.
With the only military in the world, that swears an oath not to a king, a queen, a tyrant,
a would-be tyrant, or a dictator, we swear an oath to an idea, the idea that is American,
and it's embodied in that document the Constitution, which sets up our form of government.
In 2021, General Milley had counseled President Biden to keep 2,500 troops in and around
Kabul.
Instead, Mr. Biden ordered a complete withdrawal to end America's longest war after 20 years.
The disaster that followed will be part of both of their legacies.
I go through the entire withdrawal from Afghanistan, chapter in verse all the time.
That was a strategic failure for the United States.
The enemy occupied the capital city of the country that you were supportive.
So to me, that hurts.
It hurts a big way.
But no matter what pain I feel or anyone else feels, nothing comes even close to the
pain of those that were killed.
To those who served in Afghanistan for two decades and lost family members and friends
and wonder, was it worth it?
That's always the question, right?
So a 2004 and 61 killed in action by the enemy in Afghanistan over 20 years.
Was it worth it?
But I can't answer that for other people.
This is a tough business that we're in, this military business.
It's unforgiving, the crucible of combat's unforgiving.
People die, they lose their arms, they lose their legs.
It's an incredibly difficult life.
But is it worth it?
Look around you.
Ask yourself the question.
For me, I've answered it many times over and that's why I stay in uniform and that's
why I maintain my oath.
His commitment to that oath would be both tested and questioned by Donald Trump.
While their relationship began with kind words, after the January 6th insurrection, the
two men would not speak again.
Their publicist strangement started in the spring of 2020 when protests for racial justice
some violent spread across the country, including to Washington, D.C.
Perhaps more than any other chairman in the role you have become ensnurled in politics
and arguably threats to the Constitution.
What have you learned from that?
I think it's important to keep your North Star, which is the Constitution.
We the military are not only apolitical, we are nonpartisan.
You can't pick sides.
June 1st, 2020.
Was that a turning point for you as chairman?
I think it was, yeah.
I realized that they stepped into a political minefield and I shouldn't have.
He's talking about the day when President Trump threatened to invoke the insurrection act
and deploy the U.S. Army to put down the unrest on America's streets.
On the evening of June 1st, after demonstrators near the White House were removed by force,
Chairman Milley, trust in battle fatigues, joined President Trump and members of his cabinet
in a march across Lafayette Square to St. John's Church, where Mr. Trump posed for photographs.
Ten days later, General Milley apologized in a speech to graduates of the National Defense University.
My presence in that moment and in that environment created a perception of the military involved
in domestic politics.
As a commissioned, uniformed officer, it was a mistake that I've learned from.
It's rare for a chairman to apologize publicly.
Well, you know, I grew up here in Boston.
I was Catholic and my mother and father taught me that when you make a mistake, you admit it,
you go to confession, say, 10 Hail Mary's and I'll father.
Everybody makes mistakes and the key is how you deal with the mistake.
After you apologized, former President Trump said you choked like a dog.
Yeah, I'm not going to come at done anything the former president has said or not said.
General Milley did tell us he was so disillusioned with the former president's actions he nearly resigned.
Instead, according to former Defense Secretary Mark Esper, he and the general made a pact
to protect the military from becoming politicized or misused.
It's also been reported that you spent several days, several drafts of resignation letters.
I was very struck by the one that was published.
In which you said to the president, it is my deeply held belief that you are ruining the international order,
causing significant damage to our country overseas that was fought so hard by the greatest generation in 1945.
That generation has fought against fascism, has fought against Nazism, has fought against extremism.
It's now obvious to me that you don't understand that world order.
You don't think Donald Trump understood what World War II was fought over?
I don't know what former President Trump understood about World War II or anything else.
I can tell you that from 1914 to 1945, 150 million people or their buds were slaughtered in the conduct of Great Power War.
In 1945, the United States took the initiative and drafted up a set of rules that govern the world to this day.
Those rules are under stress internationally.
The President Putin is a direct frontal assault on those rules.
China is trying to revise those rules to their own benefit.
But that's one thing to say that China is threatening that world order and Russia is threatening that world order.
To say that the commander-in-chief Donald Trump was ruining the international order and causing significant damage,
what did you see that caused you to write that?
I would say that...
It's got to be more than walking into Lafayette Square in uniform.
There was a wide variety of initiatives that were ongoing.
One of them, of course, was throwing troops out of NATO.
Those were initiatives that placed at risk.
I think America's role in the world.
Now, that is the opposite of what my parents and 18 million others wore the uniform for World War II to defeat.
General Milley doesn't just revere the greatest generation.
He was raised by it.
His father was a Navy medic who served in the Pacific campaign, including at the Battle of Iwojima.
His mother joined the naval reserve to work as a nurse.
Well, this was and still remains a very patriotic neighborhood.
After the war, they settled in Winchester, a small town north of Boston.
Almost every single male and female parent that was here,
they were all World War II veterans of one kind or another.
The whole block really, a lot of people.
And 100% and interesting, no officers.
These were 100% illicit and they had their own opinions about this too.
Including your parents, probably.
During high school, he was recruited to play ice hockey at Princeton University
and decided to join the Reserve Officers Training Corps or ROTC.
After graduating in 1980, he went on to become a paratrooper and serve in special forces.
He did one combat tour in Iraq and three in Afghanistan.
This past May, he returned to Princeton to commission the graduating ROTC class.
Congratulations to everyone of you.
And took a particular interest in a few of the young officers whose language skills are currently in high demand.
I speak Chinese, sir.
Chinese is really, really important to us.
Anybody else speak Chinese?
Whoa, one, two, three, four, five.
If you speak Chinese, if you don't mind, I'd like to get your names.
And we'll see where life takes you guys.
We, the United States, need to take the challenge, the military challenge of China extraordinarily seriously.
How concerned are you that military to military communications are not happening right now with China?
Yeah, I think we need to get that established.
We had them for a period of time and then they've dropped off.
So, channels of communication are important in order to de-escalate in time of crisis.
General Milley says he held a total of five calls with his Chinese military counterparts
during the Trump and Biden administrations.
But it was his last two calls during the final months of the Trump presidency
that got the attention of the press, Congress, and the former president himself.
Why did you think it was so important to call your Chinese military counterpart
in the aftermath of the January 6th attacks?
That's an example of de-escalation.
So, there was clear indications that the Chinese were very concerned
about what they were observing here in the United States.
Did you see some movement of Chinese military equipment?
I won't go over anything classified.
So, I won't discuss exactly what we saw or didn't see or what we heard or didn't hear.
I will just say that there was clear indications that the Chinese were very concerned.
President Trump recently said that your dealings with China were so egregious that in times gone by,
that the punishment would have been death.
It's right, he said that.
But for the record, was there anything inappropriate or treasonous about the calls you made to China?
Absolutely not, zero, none.
And now they're authorizing, they're coordinated.
Congress knows that.
We've answered these questions several different times in writing.
Were you giving the Chinese information about thinking of the president of the United States?
The specific conversation was, I think, in accordance with the intent of the Secretary of Defense,
which was to make sure the Chinese knew that we were not going to attack them.
Why did the Chinese think that the U.S. under, then President Trump was going to attack them?
The Chinese were concerned about what it's commonly referred to in the English language,
like an October surprise, wag the dog sort of thing.
They were wrong, they were not reading us right.
Look, the President Trump was not going to attack China, and they needed to know that.
China, Russia, and the war in Ukraine are now the problem of his successor.
Air Force General Charles Q. Brown, Jr.
There are also areas of concern closer to home.
Last year, the Army missed its recruiting numbers by 15,000 soldiers.
The worst shortfall in decades.
Confidence in the U.S. military is at its lowest in two decades.
Do you bear any personal responsibility for that?
Absolutely.
I think as the leader of the military, the uniform military, I think that I am part of that for sure.
I think the walk from the White House to the St. John's Church, I think that helped
create some of that.
I think the withdrawal from Afghanistan helped create some of that.
But I would also say the United States military is still one of the most respected institutions
in the United States by a long shot, by a huge margin.
I think we've taken a slip back a little bit, and I think we need to improve on that.
General Mark Milley on the Future of Warfare.
Does it make war more likely?
It could.
At 60minutesovertime.com.